ça va et toi oui toi la tienne à
thiennes fait l'émission ne vois plus je
vois c'est pour ça à mon avis c'est pour
ça qu'elle peut marcher parce qu'on voit
plus j'imagine que ça peut marcher si ça
peut aider
oui parfois c'est quoi ton parfum sont
bons qu'à charal pour sa lenteur et
pêche voir comment il va lui a il est en
pleine forme doit avoir 10 ans on
dépasse bientôt prête
et puis ça va ça se passe bien l'école
ça se passe bien on construire victoire
du conservatoire où il apprend quoi
piano oui peut-être nous sommes fais là
il est en quatrième année de solfège et
une halle passer leur deuxième année de
là nous mettre aussi doué que son grand
père et son père
aucune idée je l'aimais football pour
changer de sport et comment il s'appelle
alors à l'école lucien ginsburg du sia
mais lui il écrivit sims pour gainsbourg
les mômes à l'école ils savent que sept
fils de gainsbourg c'est chiant c'est
chiant parce que son arrêt c'est y
rentre de l'école en fleurs parce qu'on
lui a dit que j'étais une came que ton
père était à cannes et que son père
c'est un sale con parce qu'il a brûlé un
billet de 500 balles donc lui sain sans
qu il ait jugé toujours à travers nous à
bientôt à se faire traiter de joie
j'imagine donc seule touche vraiment ce
que je vois moi moi moi quand c'est moi
je lui explique que bon je vais aller à
l'école que je vais aller voir les
parents et tout ça mais avant il casser
la gueule comme disait quoi que ce soit
sur nous maintenant je suis dit tu
essayes de passer sur tout ça pire il a
du mal
et toi mais comme ça a pu piquer qui lui
a dit ça il m'a dit je veux pas casser
la gueule j'ai dit quand ils sont
atteints à hauteur maintenant tu leur
casse la gueule et de ma part mais j'ai
demandé à rencontrer les parents les
parents veulent pas passer j'imagine que
c'est pas les mômes 15 ans de sa mort le
monde va inventer que certains bruits un
billet de 500 balles mais dès que ça
touche son père
des bons à l'école
oui il faut rien oui ajoutant bien ils
arrivent à avoir 16 ou quatorze mois
yann ouais c'est un fainéant génial quoi
ça finit en tout court ouais il est
génial pour plein d'autres choses
nous sommes à serge bâtiment
une bride et où il sait qui était son
père non bien sûr atteint constat j'ai
partie avec cinq anglais reprend son
mais son père et à chaque fois qu'il a
mené débat non tu vois que ça du pop est
amusant c'est pas de l'oie de chez teal
pour les chaussures
il laisse partir le maliciel dispose pas
pas trouvé son père il est magique
il peut le voir mais n'ont pas pu le
voir on parle lui par mme bah on parle
de lui au présent donc c'est pas
vraiment bien au bout de quatre ans
choix
ça n'a toujours pas si le nil
et oh
on est tous les deux chez un thérapeute
oui je sais pas ça va marcher ne m'en
sers faut pas mourir qu'on n'est pas
trop tu sais que c'est à cause de serge
que j'ai fait des enfants moi c'est seul
truc bien que sur lequel j'étais tombé
quand il est parti et où tout le monde
disait
ce qu'ils pensaient de gainsbourg et toi
tu as dis juste une chose
serge la façon dont il parlait de son
fils la donne envie d'avoir des enfants
et justement champ du feu ouais je
pensais pas peur des enfants mais à
partir du moment où gainsbourg effet des
enfants je me suis moi aussi j'en avais
déjà fait avant mais ouais moi c'est ma
la façon d'une des premières interviews
j'avais fait c'était j'avais dit c'est
d'ailleurs ce midi mec tout ce que tu
t'en boîte avait pas peur que le petit
lulu c'est un peu mongolo hessels avait
choqué certes j'étais arrivé à choquer
c'est que tout dépend de la moins bien
placée pour le savoir
si l'amendé comme pendant la grossesse
l'enfant risque mais une fois que c'est
dans le tiroir réclame au moins il sage
ya aucun problème
ça a été ma chance vous écouter des
chansons de moi au départ ça a été très
difficile et surtout quand ils passent à
la télé et lui m'a dit maintenant c'est
la seule façon dont tu peux voir mon
père c'est à télé est morte hantz et les
cassettes
c'est tous les jours n'est besoin c'est
comme moi vous écoutez quoi il aime bien
les villes chansons ouais deux premières
chansons oui effectivement il aimait
beaucoup aux enfants de la chance mais
ça tout petit quand il avait deux ans et
demi sa chanson préférée au réveil
c'était aux enfants de la chance
bon et puis là il aime bien aimé les
chansons comme ubi bene dit tu as
initial but vivaqua et il ya une chanson
qu'il l'avait marqué c'était d'octobre
je suis l'auteur jack n y avait il à vue
j'ai pas à la télé son père était dans
un fauteuil hop le fauteuil tone hop il
y aller il a disparu heures il a trouvé
ça génial c'était magique
il aime bien toute cette époque il adore
mes pensionnaires des lilas et puis il a
une oreille presque parfaite donc il
entend trois notes il sait que c'est son
père de suite mais je sais pas ce qu'il
fera j'espère qu'il fera pas la même
chose que serge pourquoi on risque
d'être difficile pour lui comme ont déjà
c'est pas facile petit notes fumées ce
nom mais bon aussi après fonction doit
être plus doué que son père si les
moissons
nagl poursuivre en tête de course bah
ouais ça n'enchante pas vraiment m'enfin
bref avez quel âge qu'on peut rencontrer
serge 10 mars
non ça rajeunit au sahara ni personne là
tu peux me passer une clope
ouais tiens
ap la tuer mais d'autres mecs depuis à
ton avis non
je pense que c'est difficile quoi et je
suis pas me mettre trop comment j'y suis
déjà une sorte de court je suis pas une
sainte
mais bon ah non je peux être au courant
quoi tu c'était à refaire exactement la
même chose
tu sors un peu
voilà
coach jorge perez dix minutes le samedi
ça ne soit là
mel gibson doigt m'a fait des gages à
table pour que je m'assoie à côté de lui
je suis désolé de dire ça à temps il est
venu s'asseoir à côté de moi
m 6 centièmes sur la tap tu vois moi je
suis parti j'ai détourné et grimper sur
le râble accompagnement des monsieurs
excusez moi c'était tellement lourde à
paraître lourd parfois les américains ne
fait pas bon vaut mieux les des fatwas
garder l'image des gens comme tu le vois
dans le futur a pas vraiment la réalité
d'abord moi je pensais pas qu'il était
si petit ces petits points 3 rebonds ses
avocats et pour s'éviter tout par mel
gibson hockey n'ont autant il était bien
d'accord c'est tout sk preuve
gilles arrivait à être drôle dans l'âme
fatale fait beaucoup rire lui la main ça
mais bon bref
ça va changer trop tu trouves way toi
non plus c'est dommage qu'on ne voit pas
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux